The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Now, today we get to move
on from integral formulas
and methods of integration
back to some geometry.
And this is more or
less going to lead
into the kinds of
tools you'll be using
in multivariable calculus.
The first thing that
we're going to do today
is discuss arc length.
Like all of the cumulative
sums that we've worked on,
this one has a storyline and
a picture associated to it,
which involves
dividing things up.
If you have a
roadway, if you like,
and you have mileage markers
along the road, like this,
all the way up
to, say, s_n here,
then the length along the road
is described by this parameter,
s.
Which is arc length.
And if we look at a graph
of this sort of thing,
if this is the last point b,
and this is the first point a,
then you can think in terms of
having points above x_1, x_2,
x_3, etc.
The same as we did
with Riemann sums.
And then the way
that we're going
to approximate this is by taking
the straight lines between each
of these points.
As things get
smaller and smaller,
the straight line is going to
be fairly close to the curve.
And that's the main idea.
So let me just depict
one little chunk of this.
Which is like this.
One straight line, and here's
the curved surface there.
And the distance along
the curved surface is what
I'm calling delta s, the
change in the length between--
so this would be s_2 - s_1
if I depicted that one.
So this would be delta s
is, say s. s_i - s_(i-1),
some increment there.
And then I can figure
out what the length
of the orange segment is.
Because the horizontal
distance is delta x.
And the vertical
distance is delta y.
And so the formula is that the
hypotenuse is delta (delta x)^2
+ (delta y)^2.
Square root.
And delta s is
approximately that.
So what we're saying is that
(delta s)^2 is approximately
this.
So this is the hypotenuse.
Squared.
And it's very close to
the length of the curve.
And the whole idea of calculus
is that in the infinitesimal,
this is exactly correct.
So that's what's going
to happen in the limit.
And that is the basis for
calculating arc length.
I'm going to rewrite that
formula on the next board.
But I'm going to write it in
the more customary fashion.
We've done this before,
a certain amount.
But I just want to
emphasize it here
because this handwriting
is a little bit peculiar.
This ds is really all one thing.
What I really mean is to put
the parenthesis around it.
It's one thing.
It's not d times s, it's ds.
And we square it.
But for whatever
reason people have
gotten into the habit of
omitting the parentheses.
So you're just going to
have to live with that.
And realize that this is not d
of s^2 or anything like that.
And similarly, this
is a single number,
and this is a single number.
Infinitesimal.
So that's just the way
that this idea here
gets written in our notation.
And this is the first
time we're dealing
with squares of infinitesimals.
So it's just a little different.
But immediately the first
thing we're going to do
is take the square root.
If I take the square root,
that's the square root of dx^2
+ dy^2.
And this is the form in which
I always remember this formula.
Let's put it in some
brightly decorated form.
But there are about four,
five, six other forms
that you'll derive from this,
which all mean the same thing.
So this is, as I say,
the way I remember it.
But there are other
ways of thinking of it.
And let's just write
a couple of them down.
The first one is that you
can factor out the dx.
So that looks like this.
1 + (dy / dx)^2.
And then I factored out the dx.
So this is a variant.
And this is the one
which actually we'll
be using in practice
right now on our examples.
So the conclusion is
that the arc length,
which if you like is this
total s_n - s_0, if you like,
is going to be equal to
the integral from a to b
of the square root
of 1 + (dy/dx)^2, dx.
In practice, it's also very
often written informally
as this.
The integral ds.
So the change in
this little variable
s, and this is what you'll see
notationally in many textbooks.
So that's one way of writing
it, and of course the second way
of writing it which is
practically the same thing is
square root of 1 + f'(x)^2, dx.
Mixing in a little bit
of Newton's notation.
And this is with y = f(x).
So this is the formula
for arc length.
And as I say, I
remember it this way.
But you're going to have to
derive various variants of it.
And you'll have to
use some arithmetic
to get to various formulas.
And there will be more later.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, the question
is, is f'(x)^2 equal to f''(x).
And the answer is no.
And let's just see what it is.
So, for example, if f(x) = x^2,
which is an example which will
come up in a few minutes,
then f'(x) = 2x and f'(x)^2 =
(2x)^2, which is 4x^2.
Whereas f''(x) is equal to, if
I differentiate this another
time, it's equal to 2.
So they don't mean
the same thing.
The same thing over here.
You can see this dy / dx,
this is the rate of change
of y with respect to x.
The quantity squared.
So in other words,
this thing is supposed
to mean the same as that.
Yeah.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, you
got a little nervous because
I left out these limits.
And indeed, I did
that on purpose
because I didn't want to
specify what was going on.
Really, if you wrote
it in terms of ds,
you'd have to write
it as starting at s_0
and ending at s_n to be
consistent with the variable s.
But of course, if you write it
in terms of another variable,
you put that variable in.
So this is what we do when
we change variables, right?
We have many different
choices for these limits.
And this is the clue as
to which variable we use.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Correct.
s_0 and s_n are not
the same thing as a and b.
In fact, this is x_n.
And this x_0, over here.
That's what a and b are.
But s_0 and s_n are mileage
markers on the road.
They're not the same thing
as keeping track of what's
happening on the x axis.
So when we measure
arc length, remember
it's mileage along
the curved path.
So now, I need to give
you some examples.
And my first example is
going to be really basic.
But I hope that it helps to
give some perspective here.
So I'm going to take
the example y = m
x, which is a linear
function, a straight line.
And then y' would be m, and so
ds is going to be the square
root of 1 + (y')^2, dx.
Which is the square
root of 1 + m^2, dx.
And now, the length, say,
if we go from, I don't know,
let's say 0 to 10, let's say,
of the graph is going to be
the integral from 0 to 10 of
the square root of 1 + m^2, dx.
Which of course is just
10 square root of 1 + m^2.
Not very surprising.
This is a constant.
It just factors out and the
integral from 0 to 10 of dx
is 10.
Let's just draw a
picture of this.
This is something
which has slope m here.
And it's going to 10.
So this horizontal is 10.
And the vertical is 10m.
Those are the
dimensions of this.
And the Pythagorean theorem
says that the hypotenuse,
not surprisingly, let's draw
it in here in orange to remind
ourselves that it was the same
type of orange that we had over
there, this length here is the
square root of 10^2 + (10m)^2.
That's the formula
for the hypotenuse.
And that's exactly
the same as this.
Maybe you're saying
duh, this is obvious.
But the point that I'm
trying to make is this.
If you can figure out these
formulas for linear functions,
calculus tells you how to
do it for every function.
The idea of calculus is that
this easy calculation here,
which you can do
without any calculus
at all, all of the tools, the
notations of differentials
and limits and
integrals, is going
to make you be able to
do it for any curve.
Because we can break things up
into these little infinitesimal
bits.
This is the whole idea
of all of the methods
that we had to set
up integrals here.
This is the main point
of these integrals.
Now, so let's do something
slightly more interesting.
Our next example is
going to be the circle,
so y = square root of 1-x^2.
If you like, that's the
graph of a semicircle.
And maybe we'll set
it up here this way.
So that the semicircle
goes around like this.
And we'll start
it here at x = 0.
And we'll go over to a.
And we'll take this little
piece of the circle.
So down to here.
If you like.
So here's the
portion of the circle
that I'm going to
measure the length of.
Now, we know that length.
It's called arc length.
And I'm going to
give it a name, I'm
going to call it alpha here.
So alpha's the arc
length along the circle.
Now, let's figure
out what it is.
First, in order to do this, I
have to figure out what y' is.
Or, if you like, dy/dx.
Now, that's a calculation that
we've done a number of times.
And I'm going to do
it slightly faster.
But you remember it gives you a
square root in the denominator.
And then you have the
derivative of what's
inside the square root.
Which is -2x.
But then there's also 1/2,
because in disguise it's really
(1 - x^2)^(1/2).
So we've done this
calculation enough times
that I'm not going to
carry it out completely.
I want you to think
about what it is.
It turns out to -x up here,
because the 1/2 and the 2
cancel.
And now the thing that
we have to integrate
is this arc length element,
as it's called, ds.
And that's going to be the
square root of 1 + (y')^2, dx.
And so I'm going to have to
carry out the calculation,
some messy calculation here.
Which is that this is 1 plus
the quantity -x over square root
of 1 - x^2, squared.
So I have to figure out
what's under the square root
sign over here in order to
carry out this calculation.
Now let's do that.
This is 1 + x^2 / (1 - x^2).
That's what this simplifies to.
And then that's equal to, over
a common denominator, 1 - x^2.
1 - x^2 + x^2.
And there is a little bit
of simplification now.
Because the two x^2's cancel.
And we get 1/(1-x^2).
So now I get to finish
off the calculation
by actually figuring out
what the arc length is.
And what is it?
Well, this alpha is equal to
the integral from 0 to a of ds.
Well, it's going to be
the square root of what
I have here.
This was a square,
this is just what
was underneath the
square root sign.
This is 1 + (y')^2.
Have to take the
square root of that.
So what I get here is dx over
the square root of 1 - x^2.
And now, we recognize this.
The antiderivative of this
is something that we know.
This is the inverse sine.
Evaluated at 0 and a.
Which is just giving
us the inverse sine
of a, because the inverse
sine of 0 is equal to 0.
So alpha is equal to
the inverse sine of a.
That's a very fancy way of
saying that sin(alpha) = a.
That's the equivalent
statement here.
And what's going on here
is something that's just
a little deeper than it looks.
Which is this.
We've just figured out a
geometric interpretation
of what's going on here.
That is, that we went a
distance alpha along this arc.
And now remember that
the radius here is 1.
And this horizontal
distance here is a.
This distance here is a.
And so the geometric
interpretation of this
is that this angle
is alpha radians.
And sin(alpha) = a.
So this is consistent
with our definition
previously, our previous
geometric definition
of radians.
But this is really your first
true definition of radians.
We never actually--
People told you
that radians were the arc
length along this curve.
This is the first time
you're deriving it.
This is the first time you're
seeing it correctly done.
And furthermore, this
is the first time
you're seeing a
correct definition
of the sine function.
Remember we had
this crazy way, we
defined the
exponential function,
then we had another
way of defining the log
function as an integral.
Then we defined the
exponential in terms of it.
Well, this is the
same sort of thing.
What's really happening
here is that if you
want to know what
radians are, you
have to calculate this number.
If you've calculated
this number, then
by definition if sine is
the thing whose alpha radian
amount gives you
a, then it must be
that this is sine inverse of a.
And so the first thing that
gets defined is the arcsine.
And the next thing
that gets defined
is the sine, afterwards.
This is the way the
foundational approach actually
works when you start
from first principles.
This arc length being one
of the first principles.
So now we have a solid
foundation for trig functions.
And this is giving
that connection.
Of course, it's consistent with
everything you already knew,
so you don't have to make any
transitional thinking here.
It's just that this
is the first time
it's being done rigorously.
Because you only
now have arc length.
So these are examples, as I say,
that maybe you already know.
And maybe we'll do one that
we don't know quite as well.
Let's find the
length of a parabola.
This is Example 3.
Now, that was what
I was suggesting
we were going to do earlier.
So this is the function y x^2.
y' = 2x.
And so ds is equal to the
square root of 1 + (2x)^2, dx.
And now I can figure out what
a piece of a parabola is.
So I'll draw the piece
of parabola up to a,
let's say, starting from 0.
So that's the chunk.
And then its arc length,
between 0 and a of this curve,
is the integral from 0 to a of
square root of 1 + 4x^2, dx.
OK, now if you like, this is
the answer to the question.
But people hate
looking at answers
when they're integrals
if they can be evaluated.
So one of the reasons why we
went through all this rigmarole
of calculating these
things is to show you
that we can actually evaluate
a bunch of these functions
here more explicitly.
It doesn't help a lot, but
there is an explicit calculation
of this.
So remember how
you would do this.
So this is just a
little bit of review.
What we did in techniques
of integration.
The first step is what?
A substitution.
It's a trig substitution.
And what is it?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So x equals
something tan(theta).
I claim that it's 1/2 tan,
and I'm going to call it u.
Because I'm going to
use theta for something
else in a couple of days.
OK?
So this is the substitution.
And then of course dx
= 1/2 sec^2 u du, etc.
So what happens if you do this?
I'll write down the
answer, but I'm not
going to carry this out.
Because every one of
these is horrendous.
But I think I worked it out.
Let's see if I'm lucky.
Oh yeah.
I think this is what it is.
It's a 1/4 ln(2x + square root
of (1+4x^2) + 1/2 x square root
of (1+4x^2)).
Evaluated at a and 0.
So yick.
I mean, you know.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why I
did I make it 1/2?
Because it turns out that
when you differentiate.
So the question is,
why is there 1/2 there?
If you differentiate it without
the 1/2, you get this term
and it looks like it's
going to be just right.
But then if you differentiate
this one you get another thing.
And it all mixes together.
And it turns out
that there's more.
So it turns out that it's 1/2.
Differentiate it and check.
So this just an incredibly
long calculation.
It would take fifteen minutes
or something like that.
But the point is, you
do know in principle
how to do these things.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, he was
talking about this 1/2,
not this crazy 1/2 here.
Sorry.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So sorry about that.
Thank you for helping.
This factor of 1/2 here comes
about because when you square
x, you don't get tan^2.
When you square 2x, you
get (4x)^2 and that matches
perfectly with this thing.
And that's why you
need this factor here.
Yeah.
Another question,
way in the back.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is,
when you do this substitution,
doesn't the limit
from 0 to a change.
And the answer is,
absolutely yes.
The limits in terms
of u are not the same
as the limits in terms of a.
But if I then translate back
to the x variables, which
I've done here in this bottom
formula, of x = 0 and x = a,
it goes back to those in
the original variables.
So if I write things in
the original variables,
I have the original limits.
If I use the u variables, I
would have to change limits.
But I'm not carrying
out the integration,
because I don't want to.
So I brought it back
to the x formula.
Other questions.
OK, so now we're ready to launch
into three-space a little bit
here.
We're going to talk
about surface area.
You're going to be
doing a lot with surface
area in multivariable calculus.
It's one of the
really fun things.
And just remember, when
it gets complicated,
that the simplest things
are the most important.
And the simple
things are, if you
can handle things
for linear functions,
you know all the rest.
So there's going to
be some complicated
stuff but it'll
really only involve
what's happening on planes.
So let's start
with surface area.
And the example that
I'd like to give
- this is the only type of
example that we'll have -
is the surface of rotation.
And as long as we have
our parabola there,
we'll use that one.
So we have y = x^2,
rotated around the x-axis.
So let's take a look at
what this looks like.
It's the parabola, which
is going like that.
And then it's being
spun around the x-axis.
So some kind of shape like
this with little circles.
It's some kind of
trumpet shape, right?
And that's the shape
that we're-- Now, again,
it's the surface.
It's just the metal of the
trumpet, not the insides.
Now, the principle for figuring
out what the formula for area
is, is not that
different from what we
did for surfaces of revolution.
But it just requires a little
bit of thought and imagination.
We have a little chunk
of arc length along here.
And we're going to spin
that around this axis.
Now, if this were a horizontal
piece of arc length,
then it would spin
around just like a shell.
It would just be a surface.
But if it's tilted,
if it's tilted,
then there's more surface area
proportional to the amount
that it's tilted.
So it's proportional to
the length of the segment
that you spin around.
So the total is going to be ds,
that's one of the factors here.
Maybe I'll write that second.
That's one of the dimensions.
And then the other dimension
is the circumference.
Which is 2 pi, in this case, y.
So that's the end
of the calculation.
This is the area
element of surface area.
Now, when you get to 18.02,
and maybe even before that,
you'll also see some people
referring to this area element
when it's a curvy surface
like this with a notation dS.
That's a little
confusing because we
have a lower case s here.
We're not going to
use it right now.
But the lower case s
is usually arc length.
The upper case S is
usually surface area.
So.
Also used for dA.
The area element.
Because this is a
curved area element.
So let's figure
out this example.
So in the example-- ...is equal
to x ^2 then the situation is,
we have the surface area is
equal to the integral from,
I don't know, 0 to a if those
are the limits that we wanted
to choose.
Of 2 pi x^2, right?
Because y = x^2.
Times the square
root of 1 + 4x^2, dx.
Remember we had this from
our previous example.
This was ds from previous.
And this, of course, is 2 pi y.
Now again, the calculation of
this integral is kind of long.
And I'm going to omit it.
But let me just point
out that it follows
from the same substitution.
Namely, x = 1/2 tan u is going
to work for this integral.
It's kind of a mess.
There's a tan squared here
and the secant squared.
There's another
secant and so on.
So it's one of
these trig integrals
that then takes a while to do.
So that just is going to
trail off into nothing.
And the reason is that
what's important here
is more the method.
And the setup of the integrals.
The actual computation, in
fact, you could go to a program
and you could plug in
something like this
and you would spit out
an answer immediately.
So really what we just want is
for you to have enough control
to see that it's an integral
that's a manageable one.
And also to know that
if you plugged it in,
you would get an answer.
When I actually do carry
out a calculation, though,
what I want to do
is to do something
that has an answer
that you can remember.
And that's a nice answer.
So that turns out to be
the example of the surface
area of a sphere.
So it's analogous
to this 2 here.
And maybe I should
remember this result here.
Which was that the arc length
element was given by this.
So we'll save that for a second.
So we're going to do
this surface area now.
So if you like, this
is another example.
The surface area of a sphere.
This is a good example,
and one, as I say,
that has a really nice answer.
So it's worth doing.
So first of all, I'm not going
to set it up quite the way
I did in Example 2.
Instead, I'm going to
take the general sphere,
because I'd like to watch
the dependence on the radius.
So here this is going
to be the radius.
It's going to be radius a.
And now, if I carry out
the same calculations
as before, if you think
about it for a second,
you're going to get this
result. And then, the rest
of the arithmetic,
which is sitting
up there in the case,
a = 1, will give us
that ds is equal to what?
Well, maybe I'll
just carry it out.
Because that's always nice.
So we have 1 +
x^2 / (a^2 - x^2).
That's 1 + (y')^2.
And now I put this over
a common denominator.
And I get a^2 - x^2.
And I have in the
numerator a^2 - x^2 + x^2.
So the same cancellation occurs.
But now we get an
a^2 in the numerator.
So now I can set up the ds.
And so here's what happens.
The area of a section of
the sphere, so let's see.
We're going to start at
some starting place x_1,
and end at some place x_2.
So what does that look like?
Here's the sphere.
And we're starting
at a place x_1.
And we're ending at a place x_2.
And we're taking more or less
the slice here, if you like.
The section of this sphere.
So the area's going
to equal this.
And what is it going to be?
Well, so I have here 2 pi y.
I'll write it out, just
leave it as y for now.
And then I have ds.
So that's always what the
formula is when you're
revolving around the x-axis.
And then I'll plug
in for those things.
So 2 pi, the formula for y
is square root a^2 - x^2.
And the formula
for ds, well, it's
the square root
of this times dx.
So it's the square root
of a^2 / (a^2 - x^2), dx.
So this part is ds.
And this part is y.
And now, I claim we have a nice
cancellation that takes place.
Square root of a^2 is a.
And then there's another
good cancellation.
As you can see.
Now, what we get here is the
integral from x_1 to x_2,
of 2 pi a dx, which is
about the easiest integral
you can imagine.
It's just the integral
of a constant.
So it's 2 pi a (x_2 - x_1).
Let's check this in
a couple of examples.
And then see what it's saying
geometrically, a little bit.
So what this is saying--
So special cases
that you should
always check, when
you have a nice formula
like this, at least.
But really with
anything in order
to make sure that you've
got the right answer.
If you take, for
example, the hemisphere.
So you take 1/2 of this sphere.
So that would be
starting at 0, sorry.
And ending at a.
So that's the
integral from 0 to a.
So this is the case
x_1 = 0. x_2 = a.
And what you're going
to get is a hemisphere.
And the area is 2 pi a times a.
Or in other words, 2 pi a^2.
And if you take
the whole sphere,
that's starting at x_1 = -a,
and x_2 = a, you're getting 2 pi
a times (a - (-a)).
Which is 4 pi a^2.
That's the whole thing.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The
question is, would it
be possible to rotate
around the y-axis?
And the answer is yes.
It's legal to rotate
around the y-axis.
And there is-- If you use
vertical slices as we did here,
that is, well they're
sort of tips of slices,
it's a different idea.
But anyway, it's using
dx as the integral
of the variable of integration.
So we're checking
each little piece,
each little strip of that type.
If we use dx here, we get this.
If you did the same thing
rotated the other way,
and use dy as the variable, you
get exactly the same answer.
And it would be the
same calculation.
Because they're parallel.
So you're, yep.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Can you do
surface area with shells?
Well, the shell shape-- The
short answer is not quite.
The shell shape is
a vertical shell
which is itself already
three-dimensional,
and it has a thickness.
So this is just a matter
of terminology, though.
This thickness is this dx,
when we do this rotation here.
And then there are
two other dimensions.
If we have a curved
surface, there's
no other dimension
left to form a shell.
But basically, you can chop
things up into any bits
that you can actually measure.
That you can figure
out what the area is.
That's the main point.
Now, I said we were
going to, we've
just launched into
three-dimensional space.
And I want to now move on to
other space-like phenomena.
But we're going to do this.
So this is also a
preparation for 18.02,
where you'll be doing
this a tremendous amount.
We're going to talk now
about parametric equations.
Really just parametric curves.
So you're going to
see this now and we're
going to interpret
it a couple of times,
and we're going to think
about polar coordinates.
These are all preparation for
thinking in more variables,
and thinking in a
different way than you've
been thinking before.
So I want you to
prepare your brain
to make a transition here.
This is the beginning
of the transition
to multivariable thinking.
We're going to consider
curves like this.
Which are described with x
being a function of t and y
being a function of t.
And this letter t is
called the parameter.
In this case you should
think of it-- the easiest way
to think of it is as time.
And what you have is
what's called a trajectory.
So this is also
called a trajectory.
And its location, let's say, at
time 0, is this location here.
(x(0), y(0)), that's
a point in the plane.
And then over here, for
instance, maybe it's
(x(1), y(1)).
And I drew arrows
along here to indicate
that we're going from this
place over to that place.
These are later times. t = 1
is a later time than t = 0.
So that's just a
very casual, it's
just the way we use
these notations.
Now let me give you the first
example, which is x = a cos
t, y = a sin t.
And the first thing to figure
out is what kind of curve
this is.
And to do that, we
want to figure out
what equation it satisfies
in rectangular coordinates.
So to figure out
what curve this is,
we recognize that if we square
and add-- So we add x^2 to y^2,
we're going to get something
very nice and clean.
We're going to get a^2
cos^2 t + a^2 sin^2 t.
Yeah that's right, OK.
Which is just a ^2 a^2 (cos^2 +
sin^2), or in other words a^2.
So lo and behold, what
we have is a circle.
And then we know what
shape this is now.
And the other thing I'd
like to keep track of
is which direction we're
going on the circle.
Because there's more to this
parameter then just the shape.
There's also where
we are at what time.
This would be, think of it like
the trajectory of a planet.
So here, I have to do this
by plotting the picture
and figuring out what happens.
So at t = 0, we have
(x, y) is equal to,
plug in here (a cos 0, a sin 0).
Which is just a * 1
+ a * 0, so (a, 0).
And that's here.
That's the point (a, 0).
We know that it's the
circle of radius a.
So we know that
the curve is going
to go around like this somehow.
So let's see what
happens at t = pi / 2.
So at that point, we have (x,
y) = (a cos(pi/2), a sin(pi/2)).
Which is (0, a), because
sine of pi / 2 is 1.
So that's up here.
So this is what
happens at t = 0.
This is what happens
at t = pi / 2.
And the trajectory
clearly goes this way.
In fact, this turns
out to be t = pi, etc.
And it repeats at t = 2pi.
So the other feature
that we have,
which is qualitative feature,
is that it's counterclockwise.
Now the last little bit is
going to be the arc length.
Keeping track of the arc length.
And we'll do that next time.